I wish I had some of John's workouts
what I text you man i text you my wait I
wait in the yeah now oh you want me to
tell the story sure
text me well hold on let me let me let
me tell what happened though let me so
my girls stepdad was looking thick and
not in a good way and he was chasing my
son around the room and got out of
breath
no I what you need get in shape and I
said how much you weigh he goes what do
you think I go right to 50 do to 60
years no way
he's a California Highway Patrol he's
not that big he's not that he's six foot
but he has a gut thank you probably to
40 to 50 and he goes no way ma'am this
on it mmm
there's no way Papa were to scale okay
pop were to scale now now he got on now
hold on okay your boys on the road I'm a
Road Dogg I'm on the road morning yo da
name so you know that's what my on the
road more than you're on the road thy
name you're on the road all the time all
the time yeah but I'm young guys I
should be got Road dogs do that's right
I'm trying to get as good as you guys
that's right I rode out that yeah now I
come into a town where you got to eat
but this is we that's what I'm doing
spending money rolling out the red
carpet
Oh House Roth red car because they want
you to taste their whiskey they wanted
to taste their restaurant they wouldn't
they want it that's the best do it want
it people want you know yeah I don't be
rude come come to my thing I don't be
rude you're not riled the food let's
still work out I ride my Pelt on every
goddamn day but if they come a piece of
peach cobbler you're gonna try it if I'm
in Portland and voodoo doughnuts sends
me 12 what do you do what are you gonna
do Brian
well you got to eat some of them if I'm
in Nashville's and Hattie B's goes yeah
try the best Nashville hot chicken
sandwich in the world
you tried hot chick and setter to be
polite and fat then skinny and rude
that's what I said don't cut me fat I'm
just saying better to be polite in fat
than skinny and rude but here's the
pride here's the problem okay I'm on the
road a lot yeah and I said to myself you
kind of think Brennan but then I ask my
girl thick that's why I always feel
thick but you know I told my own aunt
you ask my girl how does yours I think
it's skinny I'm really gonna ask you a
holic you you look fine you actually
going that's my brother goes look fine
to me
but you feel something's off so I step
on it
take it easy a scale is an emotional
time from take it easy breathe up on the
scale
breathe that's okay that's it if you
have to bite your thumb by your thumb
the other week no reason to squint the
other week you went how much you weigh
bro I went why you looking thick not a
bad way looking at think I uh I'm
probably fit to it no Papa it's a bubble
you ain't 250 anyway you probably do 70
and it was insulting it was in the salt
things in salt it was like you sent me a
low carb are you got added some food I
know man you go you go no I'm not no
never that time never been that big I've
never been that big and you you got dead
serious and you said I've never been
that begging you said it three times
what did I text you this weekend up
let's step on that scale
Brendan topped out at 273 he's T top
that is 273 we got Eddie Bravo
Joe Rogan's myself got a text I'm 273
pounds and I'm sad I said I'm thing
about slitting my wrists yeah I'm super
sad cat did you know me don't tell
anyone I'm insecure I'm glad you're
talking about I'm talking about cuz I
know it's gonna put me if you gonna put
baby in the corner how much does that
wrap baby's gonna lose weight cat did
you think I was 273 no because I imagine
Chintu like his biggest he was 285 and I
saw a video of his like high school
talent show and you look nothing close
to that so I think is a different kind
of big yeah really weird like your your
your um I think your bone structure is
so make a swordfish because I'll meet a
guy who's a herself assorted you're so
dense yeah you're dense your brother
swordfish you're 90% Samoan - so the
Samoans have very strong dense bodies
I'm thick like a swordfish did but you
are you are like so a lot of guys say
I'm 240 but they look they have a
different frame and you're like you
don't look it you look you're I think
it's cuz you're 64 and you're also super
wide I don't know thick yeah but there's
been some markers I don't want to tell
you what about so I'm on the road I'm on
the road a lot and I'm on the plane okay
and the first thing I do when I get on
the plane is I unbuckle my keys because
it feels better in my head I went my
jeans again tighter yeah it's these
[ __ ] jeans yeah it's not lard-ass
there you unbuckle
Fator okay okay okay take it easy now
can I see a question where do you put
the weight on most in your tummy but
tell me you've always been a little
insecure about your tummy even when you
were fighting you and I go to my tummy
oh my dick oh I don't know about that
part alastair man cry my fat or fat or
dick like dicks kidding put on weight as
well my favorite is this my favorite is
you ever date girls who are like and and
it's true that I get to Maya because my
butt in my boobs I hate it I don't I
don't go ahead people rascal rinse yeah
so here's the thing Papa's losing weight
for as long as I've known you you've
been on a diet moms and then I wasn't
either another hold on hold on I wasn't
on a diet
you were not I'm 273 bread I was on the
road diet so was this road food you were
just on the road eating my girls
pregnant you know so it's like there's
just food I'm eating I'm on the road
like Drake says you know if we if we
celebrated every time something to
celebrate what are we doing I was
celebrating on the road I mean whatever
sold out the show we'd celebrate with
dessert you just get you get a stop for
the first time so I thought what I don't
want is my second child comes and in
November I can't be in the pictures with
my tits out no can't be all fattening
cuz my kids only got a picture Mike what
thought dad was the baddest dad's a fat
ass yeah cuz dad looks like hopper off
stranger things yeah
so we can't have that hoppers got a
little he's he's thick I'm hopper Brian
a little bit yeah not anymore
an athletic hopper whatever doesn't
matter at this point no one's playing
sports anymore that's bum hopper your
huh so I've been I can't emphasize
enough strict Aikido
since Thursday night Jean vegetables to
you getting some fiber in your body not
real oh I mean some veggies don't do
that out the high carb ones no no let's
go ahead and have a supplement for that
though I'm talking strict keto for four
days now really well see where I'm at
end of August okay how all my pop is out
there long going on some fiber to I want
you on so we have some fiber okay just
some green some some run a lot a lot of
spinach a lot of spinach ton of spinach
okay kind of spinach otherwise they'll
give me your breakfast
this morning at 4:00 fried eggs every
pieces of bacon okay justjust just watch
your just shut the [ __ ] up okay just
shut the [ __ ] what do you have just shut
up kill me I'm super ornery dude no bro
it makes me lean me easy and healthy
skinny and rude right now yeah I want
you polite in fat but you know you're
getting skinny in rude
I'm just saying mad at you guys but what
about a second one in here what a sin do
people send your pies that they toiled
over like not anymore bro you're gonna
be skinny and rude yep
but you always have a tendency to be fat
and polite I'm just saying I don't like
that no one said well you're all
bristling like guys let me shut up
everyone you look good well my body's
changing a little [ __ ] you man this
ain't about you okay but I don't get
exactly the same I'm getting though
you're skinny bro what you do about me
and my hopper body you toast it you
posted about about dad bods being sexy
to women yeah where'd you read that what
he's a studdy okay all right - take it
easy man yeah I don't like it out of
support in here I'm giving you support
us at Kido gym I like this you're gonna
do Kido look I'm giving you support you
just seem aggressive right now yeah man
cuz I'm mad no one said you getting fat
okay
and I don't like that I have to step on
the scale in front of my [ __ ] in-laws
they went Wow yeah I'm 73 when it's at
273 everybody went whoa is that
Christopher Pratt who is that guy yeah
that's Chris Pratt come on Christopher
all right
he's a studdy that's so impose did yeah
well he's a big boy if you're Chris
Pratt I guess they don't really care
well not anymore now he's shred your son
your son is shred Cydia yeah he looks he
looks shred City
Papa's getting in shape man brace right
to it okay man I don't like it easy way
what kind of I'm saying nothing dude
yeah you know I don't like either
all right thanks my brothers know except
no one in here you guys see me all the
time especially you cat no as a female
no one said [ __ ] you wear any clothes
all jerseys all the goddamn you wear
baggy
oh sure sign again fat your injures okay
you're wearing Hawaiian shirt there you
are
I mean know that I knew bro okay that's
me okay there you aware I look like
hopper no look listen he's a big kid now
let me ask him some back here alright
he's got big arms now let me ask you
something well you wear a lot of you
wear a lot of layers so I don't know no
I don't abide t-shirts that's the other
thing
my Styles gonna change up as well well I
don't like wearing t-shirts all the time
okay I like fashion maybe when we're
button ups from now I am dude nobody's
telling ya you forced me man - get back
what if she's not
I didn't I'm sick of this what's the
goal what do you want to get down to cuz
you when you when you did cyborg when
you did jujitsu you were to 38 to 28 I
think that's a lie price is where he got
away of the the weight was supposed to
be 225 and I found out that they were
gonna weigh him in they are only male or
to me so I was 228 okay that's not a
lies - I was like bring him up then he
was very thin he was super thin let's me
running away running away they didn't
engage but I thought I did I was
gardening that's beyond you it was great
that was like [ __ ] off he said you're
not taking my leg I got a fight not
happening nice submitted Matt Mitrione
right after that show up show the other
picture I'm in this guy like that outfit
you were wearing yeah bro I was also
highest-paid on the card not a big deal
yep look at that I love thin I am there
see the thing here I baked through 28
damn so back to my thing and good look
shout-out to metamoris yeah that's me
yep number one right guy for the world
some done anyway so we talked about high
speed oh yes I made Matt Mitrione in the
first round after that I'm sorry okay
where were we I'm not in that life
anymore don't bring it out of me Brian
dude I'm just like you dude I'm just
looking no I feel like look at me
shutting down his guard anyway you
didn't engage in nine types anyways
we're not all Navi anymore what we're
talking about here I am said I'm telling
you what word can you get rid of that
chance all right but I like I like the
thin like you bring up pigs man I like
bring up picture me shut them down no
here's the thing Brian what am I gonna
get - what would you like me to get -
well - 35 okay that's that's you 30
that's not gonna happen
sorry I'm sorry look at you there look
at the cutie they're lucky mm-hmm it's a
big strong kid there the headphones were
sold they sponsor who same ball Tim
Tebow on me okay you're you're kind of
making me angry because you're cocky and
also you're bristly so I don't like this
Kido situation for you Mason grouchy no
I'm not grabbing and by the noice em I
think I can get down to two thirty I
just I don't mind you being - sorry I
don't want to do the thousand dollar bet
listen me - 35
look first of all your life you mean the
second of all no will bring a scale in
here due to 40 because to 30 35 you
weren't for you to $35,000 but I need a
date September yeah right number now
it's September one Tambor's that's up
you can do that in a month that's gonna
be a March over then and give me end up
septum e give me a give you October
first if you want over first thousand
dollars John's not a bit York I do feel
weaker a little bit nope okay I'm [ __ ]
strong at to say okay hey dudes - are
you lifting a lot of weights no not
really I do dead left twice a week and
you how heavy did you go with the deads
what how heavy do you go with the deads
are you lifting heavy you always looked
heavy don't you I'll do 10 reps of 410
sets 10 reps of 403 sets okay okay fine
you know what man here's the other thing
I feel like everyone in here lied to me
I don't wait isn't it I feel like
everyone in here lied to me we did lie
to you know who else lied with me who
and it rhymes with Bo
alright damn it what who who's it Riley
it's a device I used to lose weight runs
with Bella ton oh the peloton was lying
to you what's that thing you have in
your wrist is that a bracelet
it's called whoop talk to me about it
tracks all my stuff like what do you
mean your stuff my heart rate how many
calories I burn how much sleep I got
it's gonna be very important during this
bet I need one of those because I'm
older I'll get you one
it's called whoop fairly peloton flight
in my entire life what's difference
between that in a Fitbit because I have
a Fitbit this is more calculated more
precise so I'm peloton my fat ass you
guys see my Instagram story I'm on there
every morning man yeah this is a
thousand calories burn yeah not a
thousand burn what do you mean so I
would burn a thousand go I can have this
and I was overeating so I was at losing
weight so you're like you're always on a
diet yeah because I was calculating my
numbers were off bro not anymore thanks
to whoop whoop there it is whoop there
it is huh
so these so what did you burn you
started with a thousand what what did
what did the whoop say you burned some
days 400 some days oh it's very oft well
off but that thing's very on very odd
because it's the most precise yeah Falls
your sleep tracks your recovery
everything damn muqaam promo code
fighter get $30 off did we just do it it
was organic but yeah that's their ad all
right I'm so disappointed myself I get
kids I got one coming no I'm don't fat
listen to 70 dude you wouldn't have a
field right take that shirt off right
now never not oh oh a magazine who did a
whole cover with post Malone did all
these big stars let's do a feature on my
tattoos yeah they go shirtless so it nah
I'm sorry that's not happening about
your sleeveless oh yeah I think we're
gonna do man it's tank top tank not
going tank
no just sleeveless we'll see man you're
specific what about your back to
everything on your back camera Murr just
muscle are you if you do that now more
more MORE
constants have a front shot or a back
shot out front back up yeah I don't
think you have you don't have love
handles though I don't think Amiata have
obliques like [ __ ] yeah
Vin Diesel it's your little tum tum that
you have a problem the lower tum tum
dude keep it up man I'm just saying
that's what I'm doing okay--man that's
way to get my grief no no am I gonna
kill you
I'm putting coal into my [ __ ] fire ok
ok keep doing it dude you lose that
money
alright you lose that money you know I'm
gonna do with that money what buy shoes
ah man too sick addressing like copper
I'm sick of being overweight do you want
to be 2/3 alive I'm a dress how I want
yeah I'm self-conscious yeah I feel like
sometimes especially on stage I'm gonna
over dress people like oh he's so
dressed up
that's me dude yeah and I want to be
skinny so maybe you'll do that and I'm
gonna Forge coats okay yeah so Bryan
want test and anavar and start lifting
seriously you are maybe I'll start doing
some real I'll get I'll get serious
about my strength conditioning and then
I'll just be 10 pounds heavier but
that's a good temp asset all right ten
pound all right to my ass like special
on yeah you look Jack I look James yeah
I'll go right to my my whole my
shoulders everything now listen there's
dr. John Chambers you put on what muscle
easily you did it right yes do it but I
need him and you couldn't do without
steroids you ain't putting temp in the
I'm not a regionally not what I'll just
being real with you no I believe yeah
same way I'm never gonna be skinny so I
need I need you gotta go on
anavar on you need steroids I do if
you're gonna put on 10 pounds a month
I need your eight I need test me any
steroids okay let's go down to the
[ __ ] Venice Beach now I got some
people I can I can get I'll go to a
doctor and cap what do you think this
pet what do you think of my weight uh
what what do you mean just in general
just in general did you think I was 273
no absolutely not I know isn't it
surprise I don't think women notice at
all and I think they probably don't give
a [ __ ] if you're to 35 to 70 I post it
they don't care they see Nick Jonas was
fat shamed because he has a dad bod now
- no Nick Jonas yeah they caught him on
him up on a yacht you sure his ball he's
smaller and he has a dad Bob yeah this
is just when Nick when
last time I saw Nick he's hot-headed
warrior and he was I mean that warrior
on what's that what's the show we did oh
boy Kingdom clone Kingdom sir and he
looked he was looked gray because he was
working out I'm he's playing he's
playing a fighter yeah look if you don't
you know what if you don't work out
you're gonna have lit up but no one you
can work out but if I mean not terrible
you know what he'd the fats protruding
through the back there and there's an
issue there sighs there's an issue there
he just got married though he's just
living his best life yeah you look like
a lot of football players are built that
way yeah they are yeah right yeah very
hairy though dad bought from iPods are
[ __ ] dude yeah 273 was super
surprising to me
heavy sigh burbles I'm playing AFL you
tall blades I weighed in they wanted me
to get to 300 that's 260 good guy
261 you get older engines window now so
take it easy oh you bet your husband for
it but I was big so it doesn't matter
for a hundred pounds yeah is that the
most you've ever benched the hot note to
me I was like three and copy like you
didn't bet on it I was like three like
93 or 391 that's a lot right 400 405 I
didn't do it that's a lot of weight Nick
Jonas a dime piece though yeah he can
also say this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]